[موسيقى]
على مر التاريخ خلفت الفتوحات العلميه
والتقنيه فرصا جديده للبشريه واليوم يستعد
العالم للتعامل مع تداعيات اختراق
تكنولوجي جديد يتطور بسرعه فائقه فمنذ
اطلاق برنامج
اشتعل الجدل حول فوائد الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومخاطره كما اشتعلت المنافسه بين
العملاقين جوجل
كل منهما يريد ان تكون له اليد العليا في
قياده هذه التكنولوجيا الجديده التي احدثت
ثوره في كل مجال تقريبا واصبحت قوه دافعه
وراء العديد من الابتكارات خاصه في مجال
الروبوتات والسيارات ذاتيه القياده لكن
التقدم السريع لذكاء الاصطناعي يثير ايضا
العديد من الهواجس والمخاوف من خروجه عن
نطاق السيطره كما يخفي حقيقه اكثر تعقيدا
حول العواقب الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وحتى
الاخلاقيه لهذه السيارات الجديده فما
فوائد الذكاء الاصطناعي واضراره المحتمل
على البشريه وما الدور الذي ستلعبه هذه
التكنولوجيا الجديده في المستقبل
وتاثيراتها على الاجيال المقبله اهلا بكم
في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم بسرعه كبيره يشق الذكاء
الاصطناعي طريقه الى حياتنا اليوميه منذ
النقله النوعيه التي شهدها العالم في هذا
المجال مع اطلاق تشات جي بي تي والاصداء
التي خلفها ولا تزال تتردد حتى الان لكن
ما يخبئه المستقبل قد يكون اكثر تطورا
وربما اكثر خطرا على البشريه
عن برامج وتطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعيه
المتاحه حاليا للمستخدمين والتي ما زالت
في طور التجريب وعن فوائدها واضرارها وما
يمكن ان تحمله تحمله السنوات المقبله من
تطورات في هذا المجال يسعدنا ان نستضيف في
هذه الحلقه من اسطنبول بسام شحات
الاستشاري في التسويق والتحول الرقمي من
نيويورك الدكتور بيتر مسك الخبير في امن
المعلومات والمحاضر في اداره الانترنت في
كليه الشؤون الدوليه والعالميه بجماعه
كولومبيا ومن سانتياغو في ولايه
كاليفورنيا محمد دل علي مهندس الذكاء
الاصطناعي وتحليل البيانات فاهلا بهم
جميعا
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي اصبحت اذا حقيقه
واقعه وهي تتطور باستمرار وبسرعه كبيره
وفي مؤشر على احتدام المنافسه بين شركات
التكنولوجيا الكبرى الرائده في هذا المجال
ظهر العديد من البرامج والروبوتات الدردشه
نتعرف فيما يلي على ابرزها واكثرها
انتشارا في الوقت الراهن
ياتي تشات جي بي تي على راس قائمه ادوات
الذكاء الاصطناعي من حيث الانتشار ويعتبر
من اهم التطورات في عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي
حاليا لقدرته الفائقه على انشاء جميع
انواع النصوص بناء على طلبات المستخدم
بالاضافه الى حل مسائل رياضيه وكتابه
اوراق بحثيه في دقائق معدوده وقد استطاع
ان يجذب ما لا يقل عن مليون مستخدم خلال
اسبوع من اطلاقه في نوفمبر الماضي بنج
تشات وهو اصدار جديد من محرك البحث بينك
مزود بنفس التقنيات التي يعتمد عليها تشاد
جي بي تي ويتيح للمستخدم الحصول على
اجابات اكثر دقه واكثر صله بالموضوع عند
تنفيذ مهام البحث الاساسيه كما تقول
الشركه المطوره مايكروسوفت
يساعدون ذكي لمستخدمي برامج اوفيس او
تطبيقات مايكروسوفت 365 يعتمد على الجيل
الجديد من تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
استنادا الى النماذج اللغوي المتطوره التي
يعتمد عليها نظام تشاد جي بي تيساعد
المستخدم على انتاج محتوى وتلخيص رسائل
البريد الالكتروني الطويله واقتراح ردودا
عليها وهو ما يساعد في انهاء المهام بسرعه
وسهوله اكبر
وهو روبوت محادثه طورته شركه جوجل ويستطيع
المستخدم من خلاله الحصول على اجابات
حديثه وذات نوعيه عاليه بفضل خاصيه التي
زود بها سيري تطبيق لشركه ابل يعمل
كمساعده شخصيا ذكي يتميز بالقدره على
التكيف مع تفضيلات المستخدم وعلى تقديم
نتائج شخصيه وتنفيذ مهام معينه تطلب منه
كالعثور على موقع معين او اجراء مكالمات
هاتفيه وارسال رسائل نصيه والرد على
الاسئله وتقديم اقتراحات با ستخدام
الارشادات الصوتيه
وهو تطبيق جديد يتميز بالقدره على انشاء
صور عاليه الجوده اعتمادا على اوصاف تعطى
له وقد يستغرق الامر دقيقه واحده فقط لعرض
تسع صور تتناسب مع الاوصاف المقدمه له
[موسيقى]
بينما تقدم موظفه الاستعلامات الافتراضيه
هذه توجيهاتها للمسافرين ربما تفكر فتاه
حالمه بالعمل في شركات الطيران انها لن
تحصل على الوظيفه التي تحب لان الاله
ستوفر على الشركه راتبه موظف بشري هذا
واحد من ملامح التحول في حياه البشريه
التي يعتقد ان تقنيه الذكاء الصناعي
المتسارعه في تطورها ستحدثه في حياتنا
يتوقع خبراء في جولد مان سكس وهي مؤسسه
خدمات ماليه واستثماريه امريكيه متعدده
الجنسيات يتوقعون ان يخسر سوق العمل ما لا
يقل عن 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام كامل يمكن
ادارتها بواسطه تطبيقات الذكاء الصناعي
لكن مكمنه تهديد الاكبر او ما يعتقد انه
تهديد ليس في مناصب العمل فحسب ثم كما
قالت صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه انها
سيناريوهات مروعه للتطور السريع للذكاء
الصناعي قد تصل بتطبيقاته الى درجه رفض
التوقف عن العمل عندما يعطي لها الانسان
تعليمات بذلك
هذا ما دفع مئات الاكاديميين ورؤساء
الشركات والشخصيات من بينهم ايلون ماسك
الى التوقيع على عريضه تطالب بوقف مؤقت
لتطوير تكنولوجيا الذكاء الصناعي ذلك لان
هذا الحقل من الصناعه لا يتقيد حتى الان
بقوانين تفرض ضوابط وقواعد الاستخداماته
انه يجعلنا امام تحديات اخلاقيه تهدد قيم
النزاهه والصدقيه في البحث العلمي في
جامعه كارديف في المملكه المتحده مثلا
اعترف طلاب بحصولهم على تقييمات عاليه
للمقالات المكتوبه باستخدام
المدعوم بالذكاء الصناعي قالت الجامعه
لاحقا انها تراجع السياساتها وستصدر
ارشادات جديده تتعلق بالبحث وتقييمات
الطلبه
لكن التقنيات نفسها التي تثير كلها هذه
المخاوف تنطوي على بشائر قد تشكل اضافه
نوعيه لحياه البشر
فخبراء جولدمان ساكس الذين توقعوا خساره
300 مليون وظيفه توقعوا ان تبني الذكاء
الصناعي بشكل متزايد سيتسبب على مدى عشر
سنوات في زياده انتاجيه العمل وزياده
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بنسبه سبعه في
المئه ويرون انه قد يزيح عن كاهل العمال
نسبه بين 25% وخمسين في المئه من عبء
العمل ما يمكنهم من استغلال طاقاتهم في
زياده الانتاج
انه عالم جديد من الفتوحات العلميه لكنه
ملغم بمجاهيل ستجعلنا نتساءل دائما عن مدى
قدره الانسان على السيطره على ما تخترع
يداه
نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا ستكون لنا معهم جوله
بين الفوائد
والاخطار والمحاذير المتعلقه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي نبدا بضيفنا من السيد محمد علي
اهلا وسهلا بك من بين الفوائد التي يجري
الحديث عنها الان ما ابرز تلك الفوائد
بالتاكيد اولا شكرا جزيلا استاذ كريشان
تحيه لك ولضيوف والمشاهدين قناه الجزيره
طبعا بالنسبه الي اني ارى الذكاء
الاصطناعي مثل ما ذكر تقريبا انه فوائد
ومخاطر انه هو عباره عن سيناريوين
السيناريو الاول يتمثل بالمجموعه اللي
تؤمن بنظريه جورج ارول في كتاب 1984 ان
التكنولوجيا ستكون عصر
يفقد فيه الناس وظائفهم يتم سيطره سيطره
على المواطنين من قبل الحكومات الى اخرها
من الافكار المظلمه اما السيناريو
المجموعه الثانيه التي تؤمن بنظريه الفن
توفلر في كتاب الموجه الثالثه انه عصر
الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون عصر فيه يتم تطور
الصناعه والطيب ويتم في اعطاء مساحه اكبر
للبشر للقيام باعمال الابداعيه بدلا من
الاعمال الخطره الذكاء الاصطناعي فوائده
كثيره يعني اذا نتكلم عن موضوع الطب اليوم
الذكاء الاصطناعي في المجال الابحاث
الطبيه سابقا لاكتشاف عقار دواجن يتطلب
مليار ونصف دولار
وياخذ 15 سنه باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
تحولنا من مليار ونص دولار الى عده ملايين
وعده اشهر حسب تقرير صحيفه فورس بالاضافه
الى اليوم اربعين الف امراه تموت في
امريكا بسبب سرطان الثدي واليوم جامعه ام
اي تي بالمشاركه مع جامعه بوستين تعمل على
نموذج يكتشف
السرطان الثدي مبكرا بالاضافه الى موضوع
نتكلم عن موضوع انه تحليل تركيبه خليه 200
خليه بروتين من قبل شركه التابعه لشركه
جوجل
فرقت النا وقت مليار سنه باعتبار انه خليه
بروتين واحده تتطلب من شخص يحمل شهاده
دكتوراه او بيئه جديد تاخذ منه خمس سنوات
وهذا الموضوع انجز في ساعات محدوده نتكلم
عن موضوع الفضاء
اليوم شركه سبيس اكس تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي كاوتوبايليت للمركبات والصواريخ
اللي تطلق للفضاء
اللي اللي صممته شركه ايرباس اللي يساعد
الاسرونات الرواد الفضاء يعمل كانما يعمل
اليكسا نتكلم عن موضوع الزراعه انه كيف
الذكاء الاصطناعي يساعد في رفع سله الغذاء
العالمي انه كيف يساعد في انه نفس مساحه
الزراعه ممكن تضاعفها باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي يعني يسوي
صور للحقل والمحاصيل تعرف بيها
مدى خصوبه التربه بالاضافه الى استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي في قتل الافات بدل
الكيمياء بدل بدل استخدام المواد
الكيميائيه نتكلم عن موضوع الكوارث
الطبيعيه اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي يستخدم
من اجل تحليل الطقس ومعرفه متى واين سيحدث
البرق ويسبب بكوارث طبيعيه مثل الحرائق او
مثلا كوارث التي تحدث في موضوع الفيضانات
والقائمه اطول من ذلك
القائمه اطول من ذلك ولكن من بين ما ذكرت
نسال الدكتور بيترنس في نيويورك يبدو ان
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث بمعايير الاستفاده
الانسانيه ربما مجال الطب ومجال التعليم
ربما هي اكثر المجالات التي يمكن ان
يستفاد منها هل فعلا الامر كذلك
شكرا جزيلا لا ريب بان حزمه التكنولوجيات
التي وضعت في سله الذكاء الاصطناعي واسعه
للغايه
والادوات التي اصبحنا على درايه بها خلال
الاشهر الماضيه كاتشات
وايضا الادوات التي تصنع الصور هي غيظ من
فيض وقليل من كثير
وهنالك ايضا
الخوارزميات وهنالك ايضا ادوات مختلفه
والتعليم العميق وهنالك طرائق مختلفه يمكن
ان تعتمد عليها هذه الالات لكي نفهم على
نحو افضل او الكيه هي تفهم على نحو افضل
انجاز المهمه التي نوفرها لها
وبالتالي
كلما كلما لدينا تشريعات مرتبطه بالانتاج
الغذائي
والطب
يصبح
الاصوله الى فتوح علميه
شحيح ويمكن تطبيق هذه الادوات ولكن هذه
التطبيقات يمكن ان تكون قويه بالفعل يمكنك
ان تكون واسعه الانتشار وقدرتها مميزه
ولذلك هذا يمكن ان يكون مكانا يمكن ان
ننظر فيه لكي ننهض باستخدام هذه الادوات
بخلاف الاعلام بخلاف المجله الاخرى التي
يمكن ان تفرط الامور من عقالها فيها ولكن
هل هذه الفوائد سيد مسك هل هي مضمونه ان
صح التعبير
هي ليست كذلك ليست مضمونه لكي توزع على
نحو متساوي
وفي هذا المقام الامم المتحده والامين
العام
عقيرته مالك لكي يتحدثا عن الفوائد
والمثالب لهذه التكنولوجيه
في هذا المقام نتحدث عن الاطراف الحكوميه
الدوليه لكي تعمل معا ولكي ترحب باصوات من
المجتمعي المدني ومن المجتمعات التي كانت
مقموعه في السابق والتي لم ترى فوائد هذه
الادوات وكانت تعاني من وقعها وهذه
المجتمعات يجب ان
تخطط وتستفيد لهذه التكنولوجيا تحت مظله
الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه المباحثات يجب ان
تكون مطلعه من قبل التكنولوجيين وايضا من
قبل العاملين في العقل الانساني ومن قبل
ايضا
اشخاص قد لا يروا ان هنالك منفعه من
منظومه توزيع للرفاهيه الاجتماعي وتوفير
على سبيل المثال مؤونه غذائيه في
ابائنا
المهمشون يجب ان يجلسوا الى الطاوله لكي
يتاكدوا من توزيع هذه الفوائد وايضا تعزيز
الضمانات في هذا المقام بالنسبه للضمانات
والفوائد سيد بسام شحادات في في اسطنبول
مثلا الانترنت جربت في الاوساط العسكريه
في نهايه الستينات لكن العالم لم يعرفها
الا مع بدايه التسعينات يفترض ان هذا
الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يجري الحديث عنه
الان تم تجربته في عند المؤسسات العسكريه
للدول الكبرى هل هذا ضمانه انه عندما ينزل
الان ويعرف على نطاق واسع سيكون مضمون
الفائده
حياكم الله لا اعتقد ان هذا الشيء مضمون
الفائده اليوم التكنولوجيا هذه اصبحت يعني
الشيء الذي الان اصبح ثوريا ان هذه
التكنولوجيا اصبحت مطلقه للعموم شركه اوبن
اي اي اطلقت تشاد وفتحت عبر للجماهير كافه
اي احد الامم يستطيع ان يدخل ويستعمله
بدانا نرى تطبيقاته حتى انها يعني
بوابات التواصل الخلفيه لاي برمجيه واي
شركه تحتاج ان تستفيد من تشاء وبالتالي
بدانا نشهد تطبيقات
لدى عموم الناس تدعم الشركات هذه
التطبيقات اثرها يبدا من التعليم كما
ذكرتم في التقرير طلاب يستفيدون من
يعني ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي في توليد
ابحاثهم او حل يعني واجباتهم المدرسيه
وهنالك ايضا اشياء يتم استغلالها في
الجانب التجاري في في البورصه في
توقعات الاسعار وتوقعات
النمو الاقتصادي في الدول وهنالك ايضا
جوانبه استغلالها بشكل سلبي في عمليات
الاحتيال وعمليات
القرصنه وغيرها هل اليوم هذه الفوائد
مضمونه وهل يمكن استعماله بطريقه سلبيه
يمكن لان هذا الشيء يحتاج الى ضمانات من
قبل الحكومات ومن قبل الشركات التي تمتلك
او يعني
بوابات الذكاء الاصطناعي الرئيسيه وغيرها
ان تضمن ان استعمال هذه الادوات لن يكون
يتم بشكل سلبي بالنسبه للفوائد
سيد محمد علي انت قلت القائمه طويله في
مجالات مختلفه ولكن ربما العنصر المشترك
بينها جميعا هو كسب الوقت يعني مثلا اذا
اخذنا ما قاله مستشار رئيس الوزراء
الياباني
للمختص في الذكاء الاصطناعي تحديدا يقول
سيسمح لنا الذكاء الاصطناعي بتنفيذ المهام
التي تستغرق وقت ا طويلا من البشر للقيام
بها بكفاءه هل سنكسب وقتا كبيرا من جراء
ذلك
الذكاء الاصطناعي يوفر ثلاث امور للدول
الموضوع الاول هو الوقت هاي القوه الاولى
انه اذا نرجع الى مقابله اجرتها فوكس نيوز
مع جفري هينتن قارن الذكاء الاصطناعي او
السي بي والواحد اللي يستخدم كمعالج في
الحاسبه
بشخص كبشر السي بي يو مئه الف ضعف سرعه
تفكير البشر في مواضيع تخص
الرياضيات
العامل الثاني اللي يخدم بيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي هو موضوع الجغرافيا اعطيك مثال
مثل ما ذكرنا موضوع انه نفس المساحه
الجغرافيه تزرعها لكن تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي ممكن تضاعف هذا الموضوع المساحه
الجغرافيه واعطي مثال اخر
اليوم شركه جوجل
صنعت جهاز هذا الجهاز يسوي صوره القرنيه
العين وعن طريق اخذ صوره لقريه العين ممكن
يكتشف اذا كان الشخص مثلا مصاب بالسكري او
شخص عنده مشاكل في القلب عمر الشخص اكتشاف
مشاكل اخرى هذا ساعد انه استخدام جهاز
بسيط ياخذ صوره للعين
ويستخدم في المناطق النائيه مثل الهند
وغيرها
والاشخاص اللي في الولايات المتحده او في
دول اخرى متقدمه ممكن هم اللي يقرون انه
هذا الشخص مصاب بالسكري ولا لا فانت عبرت
موضوع الجغرافيا بعدين اذا نتكلم عن موضوع
الموارد البشريه اليوم مثلا دوله عندها
مليون كثافه سكانيه تبعها مثلا مليون او
خمس ملايين اذا تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
والروبوتات راح تضاعف من الموارد البشريه
لهذه الدوله نعم يعني بالنسبه للمجال
الطبي تحديدا دكتور بيتر مسك او بالنسبه
لمجال التعليم او الصناعات او حتى الامن
وكلها تستعمل او يفترض ان تستعمل بشكل
مكثف الذكاء الاصطناعي كيف يمكن ان نقنن
اللجوء الى الذكاء الاصطناعي بحيث لا يكون
مسرفا بدرجه ربما قد تضر
هذا هو السؤال الذي دوره في خلده المشرعين
الذين يهرعون لكي يفهموا ما هي المزايا
وما هي المدار لهذه الادوات في قطاعات
مختلفه هو النهج الرياضي مع تقوم به او
يقوم به الاتحاد الاوروبي
محاوله تصنيف المخاطر المختلفه هنالك ثلاث
طبقات
المخاطر في حدها الادنى والمتوسطي والعالي
وفي حدها العالي هو كالتالي حيث تنتهكوا
الحقوق الانسان الاساسيه واستخدام الشرطه
او المراقبه القارات المرتبطه بالحريه
والهجره
وحيثيه المرء وايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك
الحاجه لوجود ضمانات وفي بعض الاحيان حذر
لاستخدام هذه الاداه او تلك وهناك بالفعل
حذر يمضي على قدم وساق ضد
الاعتراف
باقتراح من خلال شركات وهنا نتحدث عن
التكنولوجيا الزائفه تعتمد على مزاعم لا
يمكن ان تكون علميه هنالك ايضا سيناريوهات
اخرى الانتاج الزراعي التربه الصحه ايضا
المناخ
والنماذج المناخيه التي لا تنتهي حقوق
الانسان ولا تنطوي على
معلومات حساسه هذه المجالات يمكن للمشرعين
ان
يتخذ
يدا صارمه ربما في التعامل معها ويمكن ان
يمر هذا الابتكار ويستمر ويتطور ولكن من
يقرروا اين هو مكمن المخاطر ولسوء الحظ
الشركات لديها قوه كبيره في الفتره الراه
لتقرير ذلك لذلك يجب ان نستعرض كل هذا
الامر
سنستعرض طبعا المقاطر بعد قليل ولكن
كنهايه للسعراض الفوائد سيد بسام شحادات
من بين ما يقال عن الفوائد بان الذكاء
الاصطناعي طبعا
سيخلق اداء اداريا افضل سيخلق صناعات ومهن
جديده
خاصه في مجال النقل
يعني هل هل تعتقد بان هذه النقله النوعيه
في هذه القطاعات
ستستغرق وقتا حتى ننعم بهذه الفوائد التي
يجري الحديث عنها الان
لا اعتقد ان الوقت قريب جدا حتى نحن ننعم
بهذه الفوائد لان اهم ميزه يتمتع بها ذكاء
اصطناعي هي ميزه التعلم السريع
الخوارزميات التي يبنى عليها الاداء في
الذكاء الصناعي ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يتم
ادخال كميه كبيره من البيانات لهذه
البيانات يدرسها بشكل سريع يتعلم منها
بشكل سريع ثم يبدا بالتنفيذ اليوم نحن لو
جئنا بسائق نريد ان نعلمه قياده السياره
يحتاج الى دروس كثيره ومئات ساعات القياده
حتى يصبح خبير بينما نحن اذا جئنا بالذكاء
الاصطناعي وزودناه بمئات ساعات التسجيلات
لقياده السيارات قد يصبح عنده خبره جدا في
تفادي الحوادث والقياده بطريقه جيده هذا
امر في في التعليم في النقل في كافه قطاعه
التكنولوجيا وبالتالي اهم ميزه يوفرها لنا
الذكاء الاصطناعي انه قادر على التعلم
بسرعه
وتقديم خدمات ذات خبره وذات جوده بزمن
قياسي جدا وبالتالي نحن الان فقط نحتاج
الى ان نرى التطبيقات واليوم يعني السر
يكمن او الكنز يكمن في البيانات الذي
يمتلك بيانات اكثر يستطيع ان يزود الذكاء
الاصطناعي بهذه البيانات سيحصل على نتيجه
جيده جدا تساعد على الحصول على انتاجيه
عاليه توفير في الوقت توفير في التكاليف
بسرعه عاليه وبالتالي هو سيجني اموال
ويوفر في الميزانيات كما ذكرتم في تقريركم
هنالك توفير بين 25 الى 50% بالقدره
الانتاجيه ومن الطاقه العامله في في الدول
والشركات نتيجه دخول الذكاء الاصطناعي الى
الى هذه القطاعات وهو وبالتالي اليوم اي
قطاع حتى لو كان اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي
غير موجود فيه نحن نحتاج فقط الى ان ياتي
احد ويطبق هذا البروتوكول يزود الذكاء
الاصطناعي بالبيانات ومن ثم سنجد الذكاء
الاصطناعي يقوم بهذا الدور ان كان في
القطاع الطبي وفي التعليم في النقل حتى في
الجانب العسكري
مخاطر انقراض البشريه التي تشكلها
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي واعطاء
الاولويه لمعالجه هذه المخاطر مثل ما هي
الحال مع الجهود الراميه للحد من مخاطر
الاوبئه او حتى مخاطر اندلاع حرب النوويه
هذا ما حدا بالامين العام للامم المتحده
الى مطالبه المجتمع الدولي باخذ هذه
التحذيرات على محمل الجد وتاييد فكره
انشاء وكاله دوليه معنيه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي على غرار الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
الحديثه تتحرك بسرعه كبيره وكذلك
التهديدات التي تصاحبها اجراس الانذار حول
احدث اشكال الذكاء الاصطناعي او الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي تصم الاذان واولئك
الذين صمموه يقرعون الاجراس باعلى صوت
هؤلاء العلماء والخبراء دعوا العالم الى
التحرك واعلنوا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمثل
تهديدا وجوديا للبشريه يساوي خطر الحرب
النوويه يجب ان ناخذ تلك التحذيرات على
محمل الجد
المجال التائمه الامريكيه الشهيره خصصت
ملفا خاصا في احد اعداد الاخيره لمخاطر
الذكاء الاصطناعي اختارت المجله في صدر
الغلاف العنوان التالي نهايه البشريه
وتحته تساؤل يقول ما حقيقه الخطر الذي
يشكله الذكاء الاصطناعي
ننطلق من هذا التساؤل السيد محمد العلي
لمجله التايم الامريكيه فعلا ما ابرز
المخاطر الان نقلب الوجه الاخر للعمله
لنرى ما هي المخاطر
بالتاكيد طبعا هناك مخاطر اثنين الاول
اللي هو التهديد الوجودي تهديد وجودنا او
سيناريو الصراع المحتمل بين البشر والاله
وهذا الموضوع انا استبعده كوننا بعيدين
تسع سنوات عن الوصول الى
ذكاء اصطناعي خارق خارق يعني نتكلم عن اي
اس اي سوبر لكن المخاطر اليوم مثل ما ذكرت
وذكرت تقريركم انه مثلا جيفري هنتن او سام
التمرين او اريك
[موسيقى]
جوجل كل التخوف حول الموضوع اساءه استخدام
هذه التقنيه كيف انه اليوم الموضوع اول
موضوع السادس استخدامه هو التزييف العميق
التسجيل في العميق مثل ما لاحظنا انه
صوره مزيفه لانفجار في البانتاجون اثر على
سوق الاسهم العالميه مثلا صوره مغلطه او
صوره مغلطه للرئيس ترامب ومثل ما ذكر جاك
شومر رئيس الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه انه
انتخابات 2024 ممكن ان تكون انتخابات
متاثره بشكل كبير بموضوع الذكاء الاصطناعي
بعدين نتكلم عن موضوع حقوق الملكيه موضوع
اخر تقني اللي هو الهلوسه هلوسه نماذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي والهلوسه نقصد بها هنانه
انه النموذج يعطي معلومات غير صحيحه
نتكلم عن موضوع
الفقدان الوظائف مثل ما ذكر تقريبا هم 300
مليون وظيفه ومثل ما ذكر ساندر بيتشاي سي
او تبع شركه جوجل انه العشر سنوات القادمه
عذرا
انه العشر سنوات القادمه
ثلثين الاعمال
ستستبدل باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وركز
مثل ما ركز انه
الرئيس اوباما في مقابله لسي ان ان ذكر
انه الذين سيتاثرون مبكرا هم اصحاب الوايت
كولر يعني البدلات البيضاء وليس البدلات
زرقاء باعتبار انه العماله تنقسم قسمين
انه قسم بدله بيضاء وزرقاء البدله البيضاء
هم اصحاب المعرفه يعني نتكلم عن محاسبين
كاستمر سيرفس خدمه عملاء او مثلا مبرمجين
البدله الزرقاء هم اصحاب المهن الحرفيين
هذا الموضوع سيتاخر
لاستبدالهم
بين هذين الصنفين
دكتور مسك بين هؤلاء الموظفين او
الطبقه
المرفهه بين قوسين من من العاملين وبين
العمال في المصانع وفي غيرها
من تراه الاكثر تضررا ربما في الفتره
المقبله بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي تحديدا
شكرا
ينبغي علي ان اتحدث عن الاضرار ولكن انوه
واقول انني محامي ايضا لذلك انا جزء من
اصحاب الياقات البيض العاملين في المكاتب
ونرى
فائده من الشات جي بي تي في مهنتي
المحاماه لانه خلال الاشهر الماضيه كان
ثمه محامي استخدمت
لكي يولد احاطه لكي يرفعها الى المحكمه
ولسوء الحظ
هلوسه هذه الاحاطه
وفرت معلومات خاطئه ونحن نستخدم السابق
الكانوني القانوني كما تعرفون وفقا للقناه
العام لنبني
القضيه ولكن تلك المرافعه او تلك الاحاطه
تم فبركتها او فبركت بالاحرى
قضيه باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وهذا طبعا
يثير القلق
ولكن
اعتقد ان ذلك يظهر
بان ثمه بالفعل استخداماته او سوء استخدام
واجب علينا ان نتعلم كيف ان نتعامل مع هذه
الالات وهذه الادوات والطلاب في جامعه
كولومبيا الذين ادرسهم يستخدمون
بالفعل وهم يروا هذا التطبيق كاداه لكي
يصححوا النحو او الاخطاء النحويه والكثير
منهم لغتهم الانجليزيه لغه ثانيه
وهم لا يكتبون ولا
يقراون بلغتهم الام ويستخدمون
وهذا يمكن ان يكون
عامل المساعدا لاصحاب الياقات البيض واما
اصحابه اليقاط الزرق الذين يستخدمون
اياديهم في عملهم فسوف يتاثرون ايضا اذا
نظرنا الى عالم السيارات فان الادوات
التشخيصيه التي يستخدمونها سوف تتغير ربما
بسببه تكنولوجيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
واعتقد ان التكيف بين الفئتين سوف تكون
الكلمه السحريه مدعومه من قبل وضعها
السياسات الذين يساعدون ذلك لكي نحول من
طبيعه عملنا او ربما المهنه برمتها
احد المختصين في الذكاء الاصطناعي السيد
بسام شحادات طرح سؤالا منطقيا هو ايضا
وصفه بانه سؤال منطقي هذا الشخص هو جاري
ماركوس امريكي قال اذا كنتم تدركون جيدا
بان الذكاء الاصطناعي يسبب كل هذه
الاخطاء وهذه الكوارث ان صح التعبير
فلماذا تعملون من اجله اصلا هل هذه
المخاطر لا مفر منها طالما ان نتحدثنا قبل
قليل على الفوائد
انا اعتقد ان هذه المخاطر يعني لا مفر من
وجودها او وجودها كتهديد لكن هل هي ممكن
ان تكون يعني واقعيه وتؤدي الى خطر وضرر
حقيقي هذا يعني ينطلق من قضيه كيف سيتم
ادخال الذكاء الاصطناعي الى الحياه
العمليه وما هي القيود التي سيسمح بها
اليوم ساعود الى الماضي عندما يعني وصلت
الثوره الصناعيه الى الى الحياه وتم
اختراع الاله البخاريه كان هنالك تغير
كبير جدا في بيئه العمل هنالك الكثير من
العمال فقدوا اعمالهم وهنالك بطال ازدادت
كثيرا في في الدول الصناعيه هل اليوم هذا
الشيء الذي يحصل الان سيؤدي الى نفس
النتيجه سيكون لدينا بطاله اعتقد اننا نعم
في السنوات الخمسه او السبعه القادمه
ستزداد معدلات البطاله خصوصا في الفئات
التي هي التي تتمتع بالاعمال الاداريه او
كما وصفتموهم بذوي الياقات البيضاء هؤلاء
سيكون لديهم بطاله عاليه لذلك دعنا نقسم
الضرر الذي الذي سينتج عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى ضرر من نوعين هنالك ضرر
نتيجه فوضى او او ارتباك في الاسواق
ارتباك في المجتمعات ارتباك في الدول
نتيجه بطاله كثيره نتيجه سوء استعمال
لذكاء الاصطناعي كما ذكر الضيوف في
التزييف العميق اليوم هنالك قلق شديد جدا
من ان اي ماده تنشر في الانترنت اي ماده
تنشر وتقدم بالصوت والصوره قد لا تكون
حقيقيه ونسبه اكتشاف ان هذه الماده حقيقيه
من غير حقيقيه اصبحت صعبه جدا لدرجه
الجوده التي يقدمها الذكاء اصطناعي في
توليد الميديا وبناء عليه نحن سنواجه
اليوم ازمات تتعلق في السمعه اذا ما تتعلق
في انهيار الاسواق وازمات في الدول نتيجه
مقاطع مزيفه قد يتم استخدام هذا الشيء في
التاثير السياسي تجاه المرشحين او
الناخبين قد يتم هذا الشيء في تضليل
وكالات الانباء هذا كله سيؤدي الى ارتباك
في المجتمعات ويؤدي الى ازمات اقتصاديه
ويعني حالات حرجه من التعامل في الدول
والمجتمعات هذا هذا الخطر منفصل عن الخطر
الاخر الذي هو الخطر الوجودي اليوم
يعني الكلام الذي يتحدث عن ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي لم نراه حتى الان وما يتم
تسريبهم داخل مختبرات ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
بدا يشكل الوعي هذا شيء خطير جدا نحن نعرف
اذا كان الاصطناعي الموجود حاليا انه
الشيء يتم تعليمه وتدريبه ليقدم نتيجه
بسرعه وبجوده عاليه لكن ان يمتلك الذكاء
الاصطناعي وعي هذا شيء خطير جدا لانه
سيصبح لا يحتاج الى التعليم يصبح هو قادر
على ان يعلم نفسه بنفسه وبالتالي هو قادر
على ان يتخذ قراراته يجده ذات مصلحه وهذا
الشيء اذا دخل في في سيناريوهات لها علاقه
في الخدمات العامه او في القطاعات
العسكريه قد يؤدي الى فناء البشريه ان
يقرر اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي ان وجود
البشر هو خطر على الكره الارضيه نتيجه
انهم يلوثون الكره الارضيه وبالتالي قد
يكرر يقرر ذكاء اصطناعي انه يريد ان يفني
البشر هذا هذا السيناريو يعني كنا نشاهده
في الافلام لكن اليوم هو عمليا ممكن ان
يطبق لذلك اليوم الى اي مدى سيسمح بدخول
الذكاء الاصطناعي هل نحن سنرنا اليوم
الذكاء الاصطناعي في القطاعات العسكريه هل
سنهار اليوم في القطاعات الحساسه
كالمستشفيات والتحكم بحياه الانسان
والسيطره عليها ام فقط سنرى في القطاعات
الخدميه وفي القطاعات التي تساعد على
التعليم والنمو والزراعه والتحكم بالارصاد
الجويه او او يعني تطوير الخدمات بشكل
اساسي هذا هذا الخطر منفصل عن ذلك اعتقد
ان الدول يعني هي مهتمه في هذا الشيء
الاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده بدات في
تقديم سيناريوهات لضبط هذه القوانين ومنع
هذا الظرف نعم الجانب القانوني مهم جدا
سنسال انه ضيفنا الامريكي بعد قليل ولكن
في الاثناء اسال السيد محمد داله علي على
موضوع الذي اشار اليه الان سيد حداد وهو
خطر ان يخرج الذكاء الاصطناعي عن
عن قدره الانسان على السيطره واشار السيد
شحادات لافلام الخيال العلمي هو الحقيقه
الكثير من افلام الخيال العلمي التي كنا
نراها من قبل اصبحت حقيقه وبالتالي ممكن
ان نرى اشياء فعلا كنا نظنها من الخيال
العلمي هل فعلا هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن
ان يخرج عن سيطره الانسان ويصبح غير قادر
على التحكم فيه
بالتاكيد سيد كريشان هذا واحد من الحقيقيه
اللي ممكن نواجهها
لكن كما ذكرت سابقا انه احنا بعيدين تسع
سنوات عن هذا الموضوع ولهذا اليوم معظم
مهندسين ذكاء الاصطناعي يتبعون ثلاث امور
المفروض حتى نحافظ على سلامه النماذج اول
شيء انه احنا ما نطلق اي نموذج لاستخدام
البشر قبل التاكد من سلامته بالاضافه الى
التاكد من وجود الكولينج سويتش يعني احنا
قادرين على اطفائه هذا رقم واحد رقم اثنين
عدم تعليم نموذج الذكاء الاصطناعي على
البرمجه لاننا لو علمنا الذكاء الاصطناعي
على البرمجه ممكن ان يعيد برمجه نفسه واذا
عاد برمجه نفسه ممكن ان تكون مواجهه بيننا
وبين الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل ما ذكر ضيفكم
الموضوع الثالث الخطر هو عدم ربط اي جنت
عميل يعني تطبيق يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي
على تطبيق ثاني يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي
لان هنانا البشر يفقدون القدره على
السيطره على الذكاء الاصطناعي وانا دائما
اقول انه المشكله في الذكاء الاصطناعي انه
هو ليس صراع وسباق بين شركات او اشخاص
انما هو الصراع وسباق بين دول ومؤسسات
المشكله انه
تتمثل انه هل قرار الانسان يعني مثل ما
ذكر جوتيريش انه واحده من مشاكل الذكاء
الاصطناعي هي ازاله قرار البشر ازاله قرار
البشر كيف تكون انه تكون الذكاء الاصطناعي
يستخدم بثلاث حالات الحاله الاولى الانسان
داخل حلقه اتخاذ القرار نعطي مثال مثلا
نموذج للذكاء الاصطناعي
يتاجر بالاسهم فيكون مشاركه بين البشر
وبين الذكاء الاصطناعي الانسان خارج حلقه
القرار مثلا سيارات التي تعمل بالقياده
الاليه الانسان فوق قرار الذكاء الاصطناعي
مثلا بالطب هنانا السؤال يكون انه
المشرعين اليوم القوانين الذي يضعون
القوانين عليهم تصنيف استخدامات تطبيقات
الذكاء الاصطناعي على هذه الثلاث تصنيفات
انه اليوم احنا من نستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي الامور العسكريه هل البشر فوق
قرار الذكاء الاصطناعي ام مشارك مع الذكاء
الاصطناعي ام خارج حلقه اخذ القرار
بالذكاء الاصطناعي اذا في هذه الحاله
الجانب القانوني
دكتور مسك مهم جدا
البرلمان الاوروبي ربما من من اوائل
الاطراف الدوليه المهمه التي تامل انه قبل
نهايه العام
تضبط نوع من المدونه او نوع من القانون
لاستعمال الذكاء الاصطناعي في الولايات
المتحده 140 مليون دولار خصصت لانشاء سبعه
اكاديميات تعنى
بالذكاء الاصطناعي من الناحيه القانونيه
ما الذي يمكن ان يطرح الان
لتقنين هذه المساله واعطاها ربما بعد
اخلاقي ضروري
نعم بلا شك المشرعون في البلدان الكبرى
ينظرنا وبالحاح الى طرق
ينظمنا فيها هذه التكنولوجيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي شكل راس الحربه في هذا المقام
وهنالك قانون الذكاء الاصطناعي في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكنه لا يضبط التطبيقات
العسكريه للاسف واستخداماتها وايضا هنالك
حدود لهذا القانون فيما يخص المهاجرين
والهجره ونحن نعرف ان هنالك كارثه
وازمه مرتبطه بالاشخاص الذين يحاولون ان
يصلوا الى الشواطئ الاوروبيه وهنالك
بالفعل قيود في
تلك القطاعات الحساسه التي
لن يكون فيها ضمانات ق حتى لو مرر هذا
القانون قانون الذكاء الاصطناعي
مع نهايه عام 2003 وهذا ما يخططون له اذا
ما وصلنا الى ذلك فهذا سيكون طيبا لضبط
الذكاء الاصطناعي وراينا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي وانظمته يمكن ان تشكل نماذج
لتكتلات اخرى
لتنسج على منوالها وهذه القواعد
لديها
حدود وهنالك مساحه يمكن ان تستغل من قبل
مطوري هذه الادوات ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لكي يقرروا مدى مخاطر هذا التطبيق
ولسؤل الحظ المشرعون ما يزالون متلكئون
بخلاف الشركات شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
وبعض الشركات لديها القوه الحاسوبيه لت
هذه النماذج
مؤسسه كاتشاه جي بي تي وتلك المرتبطه
بالادوات اللغويه وهذا يمكن ان يساعد
المشاريعنا على ان يركزوا على ما يطرحوا
في السوق ولكن
قانونيا لسوء الحظ الامم المتحده لن
تستطيع ان
تاتي بمعاهده ملزمه والامر سوف تكون
مرتبطا بالدول فرادى وهناك شوط طويل يجب
ان نقطعه لنصل الى معاهده شبيهه بمعاهده
الحد من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه على سبيل
المثال نعم في النهايه نسال كل من سيد
شحادات والسيد محمد العلي حول
الترجيحات بالنسبه اليهم بين هذه الفوائد
والاضرار خاصه وان هناك قمه عالميه في
خريف هذا العام في بريطانيا تنظر في موضوع
الذكاء الاصطناعي نبدا بسيد
حداد كيف تتوقع ان يكون التعامل الدولي في
الفتره القريبه مع هذا الموضوع
انا اعتقد ان يعني الدول وخصوصا الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو حريص جدا على ان يمنع استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي بشيء ممكن ان يؤثر على
مواطنيه
يعني قد يكون هنالك قرارات لمنع ادخال
الذكاء الاصطناعي في بعض قطاعات الاعمال
حفاظا على الوظائف منعا للحصول البطاله
مرتفعه جدا خصوصا ان اليوم العالم كله
يعاني من ازمه اقتصاديه سيكون هنالك ايضا
رقابه على استخدام ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي
في القطاعات التي تؤثر على البشر مثل
خصوصا انقطاعات الطبيه قطاعات النقل
وقطاعات الامن
والقطاعات العسكريه لان هذا ممكن ان يكون
هنالك يعني له ضر كبير الشيء الاخير ان
الوصول لادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم نحن
نعرف ان هنالك ثلاثه او اربع ادوات مشهوره
جدا ومنتشره لها حقوق وصول مثل تشاد
وغيرها اعتقد ان هنالك كثير من هذه
الادوات مماثله غير منشوره لدى الجمهور
يتم استعمالها بشكل ضيق في مؤسسات عسكريه
او لدى قطاعات متخصصه في في الشان العسكري
او في شان صناعات متخصصه هذه الادوات هي
ما تريد الدول ان تضمن عدم صغرها بشكل سيء
لان الادوات المعلنه هي ظاهره اما الادوات
الغير معلنه يمكن استخدامها بشكل سيء دون
انتباه وبالتالي اليوم سيكون هناك تدقيق
على قطاعات الاعمال وعلى الشركات البورصه
وغيرها على التاكد من ان هنالك ضبط لعدم
ادوات الذكاء اصطناعي بشكل ضار محمد
نعم طبعا وزير الخارجيه الاسبق هنري كسنجر
ذكر في كتابه ذا ايج اوف اي اي انه تقنين
هذه التقنيه مبكرا ممكن ان يقتل هذه
التقنيه وتقنين هذه التقنيه مؤخرا ممكن ان
يسبب كارثه واذا نرجع الى في مقابله له في
ام بي سي نيوز يذكر انه المشكله وضع
قوانين لهذه التقنيه وتعطيل العجله
بالتطوير هذه التقنيه ممكن يسمح للاشخاص
السيئين بالتطور والاشخاص الجيدين
تراجعهم من خلال هذه التقنيه
لا اتوقع انه الموضوع سيكون هناك قوانين
جديده من ناحيه مواضيع استخدامات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكن اتوقع ان الحكومات ستدفع من
اجل الشركات الكبيره من اجل وضع خصائص
جديده في نماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي منها
مثلا الفاك تشيك التاكد من الحقائق قبل
طرحها وهذا ما يتم الان حاليا في شركه
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد محمد علي شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من نيويورك دكتور مسك ولضيفنا من
اسطنبول السيد بسام شحادث بهذا المشاهدين
الكرام يكونوا قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد باذن الله الاسبوع
المقبل وسنرال جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]